-You know, New York, y'all ain't
playing around.
I just had to make sure.
-No, yeah, we're good.
No, we're good.
-Y'all are not playing around
out here.
-We don't play around in NBC.
-But I'm happy to be outside.
-Yeah, exactly.
-See everybody.
-Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
-Look at that.
Come on.
-You can see the bottom of
people's faces now.
-Yes.
-Taking the mask off.
-Yeah, you can see, yeah.
-'Cause that tripped me out.
I was working on this movie,
and, you know,
everybody's eyes look beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
I was talking to this girl
for like six months,
but all I saw was this.
She took that thing off,
I was like, "Okay!"
[ Laughter ]
The bottom of the face
looks different, right?
I was like, "Oh, man!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Hisses ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"Put the mask back on." Yeah.
-She's like, "We going out?"
I'm like, "Yeah, I'm going."
[ Laughter ]
-One of us is going out,
absolutely.
-This COVID is crazy, man,
especially being black, too.
It's crazy.
[ Laughter ]
No, I'm just saying because I
knew it was going to be tough
for brothers during COVID just
the way we greet each other.
Like, when I saw you,
I was like, "Oh!"
[ Coughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no, no, no.
We elbowed each other.
-Yeah, you right,
you right, you right.
[ Laughter ]
My white friend.
-Should we talk about the book?
-Oh, yes!
[ Laughter ]
-You have a giant book
coming out Tuesday.
"Act Like You Got Some Sense:
And Other Things
I Taught My Daughters,"
crossed it out and put
"My Daughters Taught Me."
-Yeah.
-"Act Like You Got Some Sense."
That came from your grandma?
-That came from my grandmother.
When I won the Oscar for "Ray,"
in my speech,
I thanked my grandmother,
because I said
she's the first person
who was my acting teacher.
She told me,
"Act like you got some sense."
You know, it's culture,
but, like, when you're black
and you're going into a grocery
store, your mother says,
"Now, you act like you got
some sense in here.
Don't you pick up nothing,
because you might,
you know, lose a limb
or whatever."
So I used that title because I
used sort of the disciplines of
what my grandmother and
grandfather taught me in Texas
to try to apply with my
two young girls in Hollywood,
which in the book, you see
it doesn't always work.
But that's where that came from.
-No, I think that's what I took
from the book,
and what I love about the book
is I think that you started
a communication with your kids
that you don't talk to them
like kids.
You talk to them like --
I mean, you're an adult
and you're the dad,
but you go, "Let's talk."
-Because of what I think --
You know, it's not
a big message book
'cause it's a lot of funny stuff
in it,
but what I was always trying to
make people understand,
I wanted to break down those
barriers with your daughters
because your daughters
are going to need you,
especially when it comes to,
like, guys and relationships.
I mean, who else would
know better than us?
And so by doing it early,
which a lot of people frowned at
first, but now it pays dividends
when they really have
serious questions
about guys
that I'm going to kill.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Can you tell the story about
how you had -- you enlisted
Snoop Dogg to help intimidate
your daughter's boyfriend?
-What happened was my daughter,
who didn't know that I had
already run a background check
on her boyfriend,
he comes to the crib,
and Snoop happens to be there.
And I said, "Snoop, there he is
right there."
[ Laughter ]
"Shake him up."
And you know Snoop, you know,
Snoop walked over to
my daughter's boyfriend
and just said, "Hey, what's up?
What's up, cuz? You know?
Hey, look here. You know.
We her uncles,
you know what I'm saying?
So act accordingly, homey."
[ Laughter ]
But the underlying meaning of it
was is that I wanted
the young man to understand
that she's got people
that really love her.
So that if something does
go wrong, Snoop is coming to...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, no.
Your book tour...
[ Applause ]
Your book tour kicks off
Friday night in Philly.
Then on Saturday night
you're in Harlem.
-Friday night in Philly!
-Roots.
Friday night in Philly!
-Whoo!
♪ -Friday night in Philly ♪
♪ Friday night ♪
♪ Friday night, Friday night ♪
♪ -Friday night ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And then Saturday --
-Hold on a second.
I want to point at everybody.
Thank you.
-And then Saturday night,
Saturday night in Harlem.
At the Apollo Theater.
♪ -Saturday night in Harlem ♪
♪ Saturday night in Harlem ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to toast
to your new book.
And I figured why not toast with
actually your own bourbon.
-Oh, man.
Guys, I have my own bourbon.
It's called Brown Sugar Bourbon.
Listen, I'mma tell you
right now,
I'm not afraid of anybody else's
alcohol.
This goes hard.
[ Laughter ]
And it's sweet,
has a nice sweet flavor to it.
So it's going crazy right now.
So we going to toast
to all of you guys.
If you didn't have a mask on,
you could taste it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Brown sugar.
♪ Brown sugar, babe ♪
-Mmm! Mmm-mmm-mmm!
Jamie Foxx, everybody.
"Act Like You Got Some Sense:
And Other Things My Daughters
Taught Me"
is available starting Tuesday.